hey yes what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so i didn't make videos
for the past two days because i was
really busy uh that's why i wanted to
make this morning video for me so it's
gonna be published before market open
um
so let's get into it guys all right we
are in a very very uh difficult
situation i'm gonna analyze mcgme
uh but most importantly guys let's focus
on what is happening on the crypto
market because it's not nice
and
i think we are only at the beginning of
this i hope i'm wrong but uh this is the
reason why i want to make this video now
so first amc guys uh
so like i was saying in my last video we
broke out below 13.
um
next support was 12 but it was not a
strong one as you can see we only had
like three reactions here
four right this was not that weak one
but it was very close to the 13.5 so i
mean it didn't hold long and we are
going to nine now so we are at 10 40
probably gonna go to nine
um this might go together once again i'm
focusing guys on what is happening on
triple q as long as triple q is not at
280
uh i think that we're gonna keep
dropping all right so
uh i think that if triple q goes to 218
we can do it today guys we can do it
uh how big is it
five percent it's doable all right so
i hope at least it would be done all
right bears would be satisfied and bulls
real buyers might come back but once
again given the situation of the crypto
market buzz on equity guys are gonna be
very shy
uh so all right if amc goes to nine
i mean we could very well have a strong
bullish reaction i'm hearing a lot of
things about margin calls margin calls
could happen on the way down but
usually what we've seen before is that
those modern calls happen whenever uh
the market is bullish and we have a dip
okay so it was during the strong bull
market we had the global market was
dipping a little bit and then amc was
popping
in a situation where everything is
crashing i don't believe
hedges would uh cover the shorts right
there would
uh they would be margin called true but
they would probably reduce something
else than short positions because
they would already be losing a lot of
money because of the long position so
i'm not sure
i mean i don't know but
they have no conviction about a margin
call happening on the way down we could
uh
however have a very strong rebound uh
maybe a dead cat bounce i don't know
but something might happen around nine
next support is 7.7
so i don't know where we are going guys
but this is not looking good
uh
and the hope i have is once 280 is
reached on the global market maybe we're
gonna have some good news we need some
um regarding the once again inflation
rates
uh growth all right this is the
important things so it can come from
good news from the war good news from
the coveted anything that is uh
relieving the tensions on the inflation
and everything that is positive showing
that the economy can sustain
this environment uh so if even in a
higher rate and strong inflation
environment we have growth and we have
good earnings so this is going to only
arrive in a few months but we're going
to focus on that and every figure coming
from the you know economic data such as
the unemployment
you know whatever the cpi whatever
figure
uh is gonna be very very important for
investors to see if we are able to
sustain this
uh
you know environment so
gme same thing as we arrive on 77
support
it's hard to be you know
we we have oversold their aside we i
mean usually this would be level to buy
right usually
uh
i'm i'm a little bit worried to be very
honest about what is happening in the
crypto market so let's get into it guys
uh for now gme 80 77 support
it's probably gonna give us a bullish
reaction at least the first time but
then
i seriously don't know so like i said
triple true
280 is the level that we kind of must go
to so that
bears would be satisfied
and you know real buyers might come back
especially if we managed to have some
good news i don't know from the fed
whatever
let's see what kind of news we could
have potentially in the next few days
okay this is slow i'm gonna get back to
it later all right guys so crypto market
what is happening bad things
so basically like i showed you guys in
my previous video the lunar peg i mean
the luna usd cryptocurrency uh which
had its stable coin which is terra
uh
you know we had here a breakout below 68
i showed you that guys i gave you an
alert on discord i didn't think we would
go to zero right away let's be honest
but this is what we did it was of course
one of the scenarios
um
basically below
53 the peg was in danger
which means that there were smart
contracts triggering selling orders on
terra terrace so ust which is the stable
cone of luna
which whenever the stable coin is sold
it triggers a selling reaction sending
order on luna so this is a vicious cycle
uh that's you know a domino effect on
the downside so basically 40 billion usd
20 billion on luna 20 billion on terra
just vanished not really but almost all
right so of course this is not good this
is sending a very bad signal to the
entire crypto system to entire staking
system
um
we can see that right now the usd ust
uh usdt peg is attacked as well it lasts
two or three percent if this one breaks
guys the crypto market will really
really suffer so we need to hope it will
hold
um
so regarding the bitcoin we had a higher
volume trading for the past year or two
years
all right massive volume on the way down
below 29 000 so right now that 29
is broken it became resistance guys and
i believe we're gonna drop more
all right and then
i believe we're gonna drop more guys um
we we are likely to go to 20k
i hope we won't but this is a scenario
that makes sense to me because right now
there is no support
before
20k
we are we have one at 22 so maybe 22
will hold but
buyers are located here now right
in this area
here are buyers between 20 and 22. so
it's very likely if we go there that we
get the first bullish reaction but for
now i think that we're going to retest
29
30 maybe
one last time before moving lower this
would go together with amc going to nine
um triple q going to 280 right so this
is the scenario i have for today and
tomorrow
i hope i'm wrong but
this is what i'm seeing coming uh and at
20k we probably have a strong buddhist
reaction but what's gonna happen
afterwards will depend on what we have
on the stable cons
are the holding or not right so we're
gonna keep focused on that um i'm gonna
try to update you guys as much as i can
in my discord on everything that is
happening
um
yeah so that's pretty pretty much it for
today guys i'm gonna try to make another
video tonight after market
uh and of course i'm gonna keep updating
you on everything i'm seeing
so thank you very much for watching i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did guys please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore
i'll see you guys